i want to take you on a little trip down
memory lane all the way back to 2005
when an eccentric movie star gave an
infamous interview on the today show
here's the problem you don't know the
history of psychiatry i do all it does
is mask the problem matt and if you
understand the history of it it masks
the problem
that's what it does
that's all it does
you're not getting to the reason why
there is no such thing as a chemical
imbalance and i'm saying that drugs
aren't the answer that these these drugs
are very dangerous they're mind altering
antipsychotic drugs and there are ways
of doing it without that so that we
don't end up in a brave new world yes
there are abuses and yes maybe they've
gone too far in certain areas maybe
there are too many kids on ritalin maybe
electric shocking kid's unrelenting i'm
just saying but but aren't there
examples where it works
you don't even you're glib you don't
even know what ritalin is if you start
talking about chemical imbalance you
have to evaluate and read the research
papers on how they came up with these
theories matt okay that's what i've done
you go and you say where's the where's
the medical test
for that interview tom cruise was turned
into a national laughing stock
he nearly lost his career and he was
called crazy
crazy not like everyone in hollywood is
crazy which they are
but especially crazy crazy because he
contradicted the medical establishment
which had been making money hand over
fist slinging depression pills to treat
an alleged chemical imbalance in the
brain on the one side of the issue you
had a kooky weirdo movie star
on the other side you had the entire
public health authority
guess who was right
a new meta-analysis that has just come
out
looking at studies involving
tens of thousands of people
has concluded that the chemical
imbalance theory is
completely bogus
most depression pills are what is called
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors
ssris which are said to work by
correcting abnormally low serotonin
levels
this scientific review which was
published in the journal molecular
psychiatry finds quote
no clear evidence that low serotonin
levels are responsible for depression in
the words of the study's lead author a
psychiatry professor at university
college london and consultant
psychiatrist at northeast london nhs
foundation trust quote
many people take antidepressants because
they believe and have been led to
believe their depression has a
biochemical cause but this new research
suggests this belief is not grounded in
evidence
after a vast amount of research
conducted over several decades there is
no convincing evidence that depression
is caused by serotonin abnormalities
particularly by lower levels or reduced
activity of serotonin now
this seems
like a pretty important finding for the
85 to 90 percent of the public that
according to surveys believes in the
chemical imbalance theory
this seems like a really big finding for
the millions of americans one in eight
who take these depression pills to
correct a chemical imbalance that
apparently does not exist
for the 1 in 29 american teenagers and
younger who have been prescribed these
drugs
under false pretenses
and it's good that after decades of
pharmaceutical companies peddling these
drugs often through incessant tv
commercials touting the theory and
minimizing the considerable side effects
it's good that now it's come out that
there was never any scientific evidence
for the theory that's good better late
than never but it leaves one nagging
question
how did tom cruise know this back in
2005 how did a guy
whose job it is to look good on camera
know more about psychiatry than the
entire medical establishment and
mainstream media 17 years before this
analysis came out forget tom cruise for
a second
forget the depression drugs for a second
how is it how is it that a bunch of
weirdo bloggers and fringy tweeters and
alex jones a frequently shirtless radio
host who yells into a microphone how is
it that all those people
have a much better record on kovit
and the vaccines than say
dr fauci rachelle wolenski the world
health organization and the entire
public health establishment how is it
that i
okay and not uh i don't you know i hate
to say i told you so how is it that i a
guy with no higher education than a
bachelor's in history and italian poetry
how is it that i
and most of you most of whom do not have
medical degrees how is it
that every single time we contradicted
the public health establishment and
their propagandists in the press and big
tech on covid over the past few years on
the wuhan lab on mortality rates on the
danger to young people on the efficacy
of the vaccines against infection on the
efficacy of the vaccines against
transmission on the relation between
vaccines and menstruation on the risks
of the mrna technology the list goes on
and on on every single part of it how is
it
that we were always right
and the authorities were always wrong
ignorance on their part
malice
greed
indifference perhaps
whatever it is
it turns out that the people our
establishment has maligned as crazy for
decades
we're right all along
and the only people who seem crazy today
are the ones who still think those
authorities have even one ounce of
credibility right now go to puretalk.com
enter promo code knowles podcast you
need to switch to puretalk for a couple
of reasons one because americans are
getting pinched right now the cost of
everything is going up and unbelievably
you can save two-thirds on your cell
phone you ca what are you paying right
now 80 90 bucks a month and you you are
paying it to those same three or four
big cell phone companies what if i told
you you can get the same quality talk
text data for way way less money if you
switch to pure talk same phones same
highest and coolest phones it's just
amazing same fabulous 5g network so
that's one reason you've got to switch
it's you're just throwing money out the
window right now people can't afford to
do that right now
the other reason is puretalk sponsors
the voicemail bag which is my favorite
segment of the show these cries are
great supporters of the show they've uh
they're a veteran-owned company with a
customer service team right here in
america as american as apple pie go to
puretalk.com right now select a plan
enter promo code knowles podcast and on
top of the already amazing savings you
can save 50
on your first month switch over today it
takes less than 10 minutes which is
insane i know it's insane because we've
been so battered around by the cell
phone companies puretalk will make it
super easy save you a lot of money promo
code knowles podcast k-w-l-e-s
p-o-d-c-a-s-t all one word at
puretalk.com
good morning smokey mike this is julia
your number one fan girl today i have a
little bit more of a serious question
my best friend is planning on working at
bp starting august 1st as an engineer
this will be her first
job as an engineer however she just
found out that bp
is paying for its employees abortions
she's a very devout catholic very
pro-life she wouldn't even get the
fauciouci because of the abortion
connections that it had so you can just
imagine her moral qualms in this
situation as well
my question is do you think that it
would be morally okay for her to work at
bp while they're paying for their
employees abortions or should she seek
employment elsewhere thank you so much i
look forward to your answer
short answer is i do think it would be
morally okay but it is a moral question
the reason i think it's okay
is because we're discussing not a direct
uh
engagement with evil but an indirect
participation with evil you're working
for a company and the company has a
certain insurance policy and the
insurance policy covers travel for
people who want to go get abortions
which is very very bad but it's pretty
indirect
i
i suspect most companies in the country
if not the vast majority of companies in
the country have similar policies
or will institute similar policies in
the wake of the dobbs decision
i think the government i'm certain the
government has that policy
many govern so does that mean that it
would be immoral to work a government
job i i don't
necessarily think so the military pays
for abortions does that mean it's
immoral to serve in the american
military i at a certain
at a certain point i i think the the
participation
is so indirect and and the presence of
this is so ubiquitous that uh
it would be licit to do so uh
but
should she
i don't know i mean that that's a
question for her what what
degree of participation and evil is she
willing to
tolerate to exist in the world
uh
if if my company if i were working for a
company that we're going out
and
promoting abortion sponsoring planned
parenthood donating lots of money to
planned parenthood having them i i
probably would quit and go to a company
that was a little bit more sane but if
we're talking about essentially
insurance policies and benefits i just
don't know how you can avoid that in the
modern world and as long as the the
participation's indirect perhaps it's
tolerable i'm so glad you like that clip
guys i'm i'm very close to a million
subscribers i really want to hit it i
want to get that gold play button i want
to put it right outside of my office and
when ben sees it he's going to be angry
he's go and he's not and that's going to
be awesome and that's going to be a fun
thing put
that
plaque on my wall make sure you ring the
bell subscribe get the notifications
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you